there's little geniuses in Marvel year
Batman won't beat them with ragtime
we've we're probably the tribe time he
would rate them he won't be the winner
rap time Bruce Wayne will take out God
himself
okay God himself God himself oh dear God
I didn't know we were supposed to bring
props you want to know I'm not even
wearing anything call me personally
trust what with this bro I know it's if
we were supposed to bring props I would
have bought like talent or something
good come on bring me another table and
I will slide that come on don't do this
don't do this that's that's not either
commit or don't this is not no no I say
this why I disagree God come on Nick
God's Lake yeah iconic God coding yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right listen Batman
and Superman are like the biggest
Shapiro's on the planet
kryptonite as a term is just used freely
I don't even think there's a copyright
on it I think like any sitcom Camila oh
no that's my kryptonite oh no he's my
kryptonite she's my kryptonite you can
just say that you know why is it
that's osmosis into like social into
society that's like the idea is just
like they're saying like I'm retreating
to my Batcave you don't have to be
Batman to say that because these things
have seeped into society they are we are
one with them this is it-- these are
iconic movies guy didn't you talk about
acrylic things okay cool
it's called school in 1941 yes we make
our punching world oh okay I cut your
punching Hitler it was so good they did
it again for issue two but if angle yeah
yeah that's iconic iconic itself
Superman is for Nazis its iconic
characters yeah here is lower iconic
than Superman hope it was the old truth
looping we're gonna get angry Hawking
that you know people say anything
that's a good point they do when they
when I talk about okay fair enough we'll
talk about science first week we'll
think about is twenty stock little took
what Batman
Bama small scientist well he does
science type of finger technology all
the time does catch its parent only no
new Tony Stark is for thirteen years
like before 2007 no it's too iconic how
did it will you see not as iconic as a
character who's been around for over
seven times since black pepper came out
now how do you see call what kind of
forever
what kind of worried about happy times
like you and maybe like six or seven
other people success I'm lying that's
terrible sorry okay you know what this
question is about right take our time
yeah we wrap time Bruce Wayne will take
out God himself
okay God himself God himself wait okay
prep time there's a little geniuses in
Marvel year yet marveled legs
Batman won't beat them with Baghdad
we've Brett with we're pretty when we
describe time he would rate them he
won't be them okay listen to this list
those people for me that okay twenty
stock yeah as long as dark yeah to east
to narcissistic is to ease to up his own
ass he's too obsessed with himself and
he will allow yourself to give beer
butter bats easily you know Batman owes
do he'll kidnap pepper
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah they got you decent what spider-man
heroes gallery alone don't do this
because you know - rokka rokka scan
every vow who's Batman's roles carry me
hands down
rivals you didn't you couldn't even
bring yourself to st. beats because it
doesn't it won't was it it actually I'm
not here about rivals I'm here about
Batman's is better no it's not my line
Piderman Superman come on I come on hit
me come on let's do a little further for
the sake for just to be generous to you
as an act of charity I'm gonna take
Joker off the table okay how much I
believe most Marvel villains are just
dark versions of the hero so lie even if
you want to go with MCU
I can list off to you the amount of MCU
movies or we're in the first movie the
bad guy at the end of it is just the
good guy in a dark costume okay like a
lot of that there's a lot more intrigue
I would say from some of the DC swords
oh my son and Superman dock that's all
years he's got the same powers of
Superman your fingers thought that's
what sorties yeah but he's all
Superman's biggest villain is he he's
Lex Luthor which is actually an
incredibly interesting idea that the
most powerful man in York and used Jesse
who to pay you
Mazal cooling Riddler like Jesse
Eisenberg yeah yeah I guess a stick
actor and he goes don't the rake capes
are coming red capes are coming there
that was mildly don't this home I dare
you oh man I'll bring Joker back up from
down here if you keep this up I don't
have to bring jobs are hard to bring
Heath Ledger and Joaquin Phoenix and
Jack Nicholson into this I don't need to
lose your best villain from your MC you
want this you know you're gonna go with
mister mister you're gonna do this and
the tennis is that no no no who is it I
will shake might be old and the reason
why I say that Martha Foster and I did
he just this those movies didn't know
[Music]
I feel so harsh if he was alive I'd be
like yeah now I'm gonna have to go with
a great look quiz where I didn't know
the guy but look what he's done for
example he was figure we've done
spider-man for example that was his idea
that was his own concepts raw by himself
right when he's doing it now making the
all these characters yeah they're made
he made him so relatable and even they
even the concept of introducing ethnic
minorities into the comics as well
yeah very unique yeah that was very
unique and I can't look him for that
he done it so suddenly onto a dew point
where he's usage Falcon black padfone
new page come on
he made Ben Grimm Jewish and he's yeah
yeah exact he's cultivation say instead
of just make it just a four out
whitewash he done it in a way where he
went to involved everyone because he
wanted make bring the real world into
comics and vice versa
yeah I yeah I can see some sense in that
[Music]
yeah okay look at the last couple of
movies you got birds of prey Aquaman
Shazam yeah
Wonder Woman yeah in between there is
justice Lee forget about that terrible
movie but those four movies Aquaman
Shazam Wonder Woman and birds of prey
yeah they all have personality one of
the things that I really enjoy about the
DC motor movies is that they are
prepared to be bad they are they are
prepared to risk being a piece of crap
in favor of having some level of like
weird different personality with a
serving they take too much risks I think
the mechanism via which DC will catch up
is by saying we're not going to do what
Marvel do which is cookie cutter movies
that all have some level of similarity
but Marvel is practically like IKEA of
superhero films at the moment everyone's
gonna end up with the same thing but the
thing is Marvel at least one person
Kevin Feige is always seen and super
seen at all
they all have lemon soother kind of like
that though I mean granted Kevin Feige
super Jeep but the thing is that they
have a sick plan and some things are
uniform it goes together with it you
understand
while DC is this mishmash for the sake
of argument why do you need to have a
plan of where we're going for why can't
you just make a good movie
okay the Marvel movies have given you
the expectation that it all needs to
come to this big [ __ ] crescendo
and it doesn't
[Music]
[Laughter]
ruining cinema cinema they're ruining
film oscar-winning superhero movies are
ruining cinema all of these oh you know
Martin Scorsese is gonna be outside to
bang us up he can try out gonna shoot
beside you but there's no way movies the
endgame just endgame let's forget
everything else
anger just talked about in game how much
was lying right now that's how good the
memory of endgame is when you come away
from memories from a cinema like that
midnight showing like a hundred people
packed out cinema how is that bad for
cinema exactly you really feel how could
it be bad how many people I know that
exclusively watched their movies by like
streaming them on a dodgy Korean website
you all went to the cinema for endgame
this is a lot that is a lot especially
in Martin Scorsese's Lincoln may he rest
completely he said he hates the money in
his pocket I didn't even like the
Irishman
I mainly just want to talk about 90's
cartoons that's like my favorite thing
in the swing it wasn't talked about
comics and rich young me you have the
same level of knowledge at information
you would small been cheatin I am I
should've got Diet Coke I'm a bit
confused over your insistence that we
call it scram because because like
autumn of all the world it's like it
just lie just shows a lack of education
cuz scratched means scram just means any
foods it's amis it's not a particular
meal scram just seems like leftovers
like rat foods like do you think bins